岩尾マラ長のドッキリは
少し過激な感じなんで怖いなぁって思う方は見るのをやめておいてください
今日の時はですね
ちょっとの容器で申し訳ないんですけど今日の時ずつ方はこちらです
食紅凸形ペイントなんですけど
あの今から強いがオレンジに遊びに来るんですけど僕がこのピッチのリーと食紅を使っ
ても殺された感じ
もう簡単に殺人事件状態でそこに寝てた時の後輩がを蕩かせ
どういう反応する
そういうのはちょっとやろうと思いますこれはねもうドッキリというかねぇ
もう
後輩がどんな反応して経過すよ僕物を進んでて笑われたら僕はもう彼らしいし
本当にねこう後輩通りたところでーしょんシッポ駿台関係が試される
まあ一大イベントといっても過言ではないでしょ今日の突起でございます
アメリカで真似しないで下さいよねほんとに逆上してっこられそうで怖いんだよ
早速ちょっとメイキングしていきましょう
魚
好きだこれはドッキリのためなら冊のいつまで2万円も油断で家を取ってるにかける
情熱がな
そこら辺の奴は違うからさ
という方でしょうか
難しいんだよね何回かにこうやられてる肝臓を出せるかっていうところ
[音楽]
もう
これからよね
ほっん
もうこれはタウンあいつするなぁ
俺削除されないのかな youtube の人これあの家じゃないんですからね地の利
とは側面に何であれですよねさみんなコンテンツじゃないですかね
強いっ
[音楽]
ねうん言えばをなつれこんだけつい中でたらもう頭って死んでる人って思ってそうです
これ
とっていた
[音楽]
のしきた人一人としておきたいことマンサ
この感じらー
よしよしよしです
じゃあこの感じでいきます
他のクレーンで入ってきた労組で倒れてる設定なんだよ
いきます
[拍手]
[音楽]
何ちょっと待っていっ
たねー
今からし直します
e 4 b 種
ます
e 7